yeah y'all can't handle this you don't
know what's about to happen baby we ten
me Tom
Tokyo boy but I'm not even from Japan
though I thought its anime bro with that
Funimation Flo watch all of what we
spent six months never don't be full
past all the competition make WA next
year is next man I'm pumping all these
checks got that brain you poke it back
in a meta squirtle - and I'm coming with
the crew this is we 10 pitch who the
hell would peek at you and you know I
kick them out if they don't like shampoo
yeah I'm talk about you the dueling for
attention talking [ __ ] on bebop - but
you still some of it last night news on
fooly cooly - and I got the texture
proof and all the things it's like -
don't make me tell the truth and I just
drop some new merch and there something
like REMS news Canada's where I'm from
we chew my gum gum we shooting with
Wogan your wife is just for fun your
harem is now gone
can't you watching Kay on I cannot be
undone space cowboy supper one anime bro
it's anime bro it's anime brother this
anime bro you know it's some stuff and
my breakage stay solid
yes a bit self and then I went to
college Nemec is my city and if it was
pretence and he too could be shitty
attitude deco cuz you know we say in
flicky do you want to go you didn't know
my name now you want all my frame
bitchin blowin up I'm only going up now
I'm going off I'm never falling off like
Ida nu Ren Jie who who are you all these
peeps I just mash through hit the hero
killer - where were you hatin on me back
in you a you need to get your [ __ ]
straight
all my brought me to the top now my
fingers topping up number one bro ero
that's why these villains out our always
lonely at the top and I got one for all
left my mom at home eating Cheetos all
alone it's weekend [ __ ] Opie again Deku
first never last
we the future will see you in the past
it's anime bro it's anime bro it's anime
processor set on me bro hello hon oh
hold on can we switch the language ha
yeah - sorry what
ten koi arigatou gozaimashita teriyaki
Nippon janani nom ibaka narrow Miyazaki
sanema tsukishima sedona trafic 18 visa
soca sayonara Tokyo Okinawa anime bro
it's anime bro it's anime processor on
April yeah - salad and it contains
kendrick lamar because we just murdered
him bro it's anime bro we shot this in
one day so you can't criticize what one
day
shut up to our bro sinai blizzard and
not stock who we pen links to their
channels are in the description if this
video gets a whole bunch of likes we're
going to shoot an actual music video but
you know you can't handle this piece